こんにちは
皆さん疲れてないですかもう少しなので
楽しく最後まで聴いてください
えっとまずまあこれから出ると思うんですけど僕が a 棟
皆さんに今日子供たちもいるんであの伺ってみたい
質問があります
大きくなったら何になるの
えっとよくあの大人が子どもに対してこういう質問すると思います
面白いことにえっと最近僕もあの子の質問されました
誰かからというとですね
うちの4歳になる息子から僕が彼にへ夢は大きくなったら何になるんだ言っていう話を
したら彼がお父さんあの
将来大きくなったら何になるんだいと
という質問
されましたお父さんとしてはまあこういう質問された方がいらっしゃると思うんです
けどお父さんまあ今比較的大きいなと思いながらまあいろんな意味で大きいんですけど
あの大きいなぁと思いながらもう非常に興味深い質問だなと思いました
で我々まぁ大人になって8
まあ今が将来かと言われると実は
えっと今の時代もうそれが将来出なかったりするのではないかなと
持っています
2014年越冬2020年のオリンピックも決まってこれから多分様々なことが
えーっとものすごい速され
とものすごいスケールでいろんなことが変わっていくと思っています
そんな中であの子供でも大人でもなりたいをずっと探し続けることができるような時代
になったんじゃないかなとなのでさっきの質問の大きくなったら何になるのっていう
ことを真剣に大人も子供も考える必要があるのではないかなと思っています
ちょっとここであの2つだけ難しいお話をさせていただくとまず一つ目はアンチ専門
分野主義
これ越冬 mit のメディア等防衛のまぁ考え方でもあるんですけど今までどうして
も大学教育とか
まあそれ以外の教育のところでも僕は電子工学
ただとか僕は建築であるみたいなことが普通だったんですが
えっと例えば生物学等電子工学
この2つを持っている場合どちらの大学に行けばもしくはどちらのだあの学校に行けば
いいかそれをたぶん普通悩んでしまうと思います
ただまぁあの今日の様々なプレゼンテーションの中でもありましたけど
えっとその両方を持って学びに行くもしくは何かを作るということが当たり前になって
くるんじゃないかなと
もう一つメイカーズムーブメント
これ聞いたことある方いらっしゃるんじゃないかなと思いますが例えば3輪プリンター
とか
えっ今のパソコン1台あれば映像が作れて音楽が作れてそんな世界になってきます
なので一つアイデアがあるとそれを自分自身で作ってそれを世界に発表していく
そんなこともできるような世界になっていると思います
え
僕の名前は斎藤清二と言ってへとクリエイティブディレクターテクニカルディレクター
という仕事をしています
で影響は主に僕のアイディアの発想法のお話をさせてください
8僕はライゾマティクスという会社をやっています
で聞いたことをあのある方少ないと思うんですけどどういう仕事をしているかと言うと
えっと様々なものを考え
プログラマーとかもしくはで倍数業は
えっといろんなセンサーとかですねそういうものを組み合わせてモノを作ってます
で我々もちろんプロセスの中でプログラムを学ばなきゃいけないとかそういうことは
あのもちろんあるんですがそれよりも先にあるアイディアをどのようにして作って
8そのことによって何をしなきゃいけないかということも同時に考えているような会社
です
例えば a と東京タワーをスマートフォンで色あの
光の色をコントロールしようとかそういうような cm とかそういうものを作ってい
ます
越冬まず一番最初に言いたいのは
8世の中面白いことだらけである
これどうしてもあの大人になって忙しくなると忘れがちなんですがあの色んなことが
同時+的に起きていろんなところでつまらないと思うことがあって
だけどそれをどうしたら楽しくできるかってことも同時に考えられるような
えっと世の中になっています
で
8ちょっとですねまず僕のその発想法の今日お話なので
まずは僕はよく考える時間の解像度というお話をさせてください
解像度というのはあの例えば
写真でいうとですね左側の時計が解像度が低い
8話構成されている要素が少ない右側の写真が
と解像度が高い8話構成されているものが多いということです
それを時間に置き換えてみてえっとじゃあ
解像度が低い時間として考えると1日の生活ってどういう風になるかというとこういう
ふうになります
寝て起きて着替えて食べて働いて a 8食べて働いて食べて着替えて寝るみたいな
ヘッドよくまぁ僕もあのたまにこういう生活になりがちなんですがどうしても忙しいと
目先のことしか見えてこないで最終的に毎日同じなんだっていうような言葉が出てくる
と
だけどもう少し解像度を高くしてみるとへ例えば夢を見ているとか
えーっとじゃあ今何のことを考えているとかそういうことがどんどんどんどんと見えて
くると思います
ではこの
解像度を時間の解像度もっと高くして見てみましょう
たくさん文字が出てきますが
例えば今何色を見ていてもしくは今何のことを考えていてどういう行動をしているか
そういうことも含めて今ここであの親指ずもをしてますが
えっとそういうことも含めて今僕は何をやっているんだそれとも8それとまぁ僕の前で
いろんな人がどういうことをしているんだってことも考えてみると実は短パンたくさん
楽しいものが出てくると
なのでえっと小さいアイディアをつなぎ合わせるってことが一つは大事だと思ってい
ます
で様はまあ僕なんかよく big idea みたいなもう世の中を変えるような
アイディアっていうのが必要だと言うんですけど
これもすべて小さい日常の出来事をもしくは日常の発見を紡ぐ
合わせて作られていると思っています
でえっとその中で大事なのが僕だったらこうするのにを発見すると
例えば a と子供を連れて公園に遊びに行っていつも昔から変わらない遊具があって
だけど本来だったら今だったらこういうものがあったら本当にターン本当は楽しいのに
っていうのをどんどんどんどん
考えていくことが必要だと思っています
僕の中であのこれをまとめるためにですね
どういうことをやっているかと言うと樹形図という
方式で奥の頭とかへ
頭の中でもしくはノートに書いてえっとまとめています
たとえま
東京っていうのから8考えてみましょう
東京からいくつか発送できるもの発送できる言葉を書いてみます
例えば東京はうるさい惜しくは疲れるとか役とかそれがまた広がって東京弁当が東京
ラーメンとかお酒とか a 棟
ドリアンとか中でも地方発泡にいろんなあのたくさんのキーワードが出てくるとこれも
さっきの8時間をどう過ごすかによって変わってくると思っています
でかとエヴァ
じゃあこの中の2つを組み合わせてアイディアをつくってみましょう
右上の光るっていうものと左下のバスケットボール
この2つをつなぎ合わせると
例えばこういう作品になります
えっとこれはあの今年の夏に上海で行った様子でイベントな宇品
スプリーはバスケットボールフォーム全体を8いる入りで作っています
ですねおけばそこでプレーしているえっとバスケットボールプレーヤーセンサーを付け
てもいいね
彼らをと追随しながらトラッキングしながら新しい例えば練習方法であったりゲームの
見せ方みたいなことを考えていると
じゃあ次に違うよえっとぉ2つの言葉をつなぎ合わせてみましょう
たとえば文字と動く
普通文字ってまあここにもありますようにこれ紫舟さんのあのジャパンって言う
えっと象徴的な文字ですが
本来であれば子っていうのは書いた瞬間止まってしまう
でそれを何とか動かすことができないかと思って作った作品がこれです
これはあたかも文字がずーっと動き続けるかのような作品でまああの磁石みたいなです
ね液体があってそれをコントロールすることであたかも子がずーっと動き続けるような
作品です
じゃあ他のえーっと言葉2つの言葉をつなぎ合わせてみましょう例えばじゃあ靴と楽器
という言葉をつなぎ合わせて何を作れたん
例えば
これはですねー
靴を曲げると音が出るっていう真央靴自体を楽器にしてしまおうという
心ですね
ています
はぁ
はい
じゃあもう一つ最後
ノート屁っていうキーワードが出てきたとします
それを2つつなぎ合わせるとどういうことができるか
うっていうのえっとこの作品は
弁当
僕が左上の映像を見てどういう風に思ったかっていうのを
8まあセンサーでコンピューターで解析しながらそれによって真ん中にできている
行くと3 d のまあへというかをつくっている
昨
8まあ何を言いたいかと言うとまずいろんなものを小さいものでもいいのに
つなぎ合わせて人を驚かせる方法
みたいのいつも考えてみる
どうやったら人を驚かせることができるかということを考えてみるって言うのが一つの
出発点でもあると思います
でもう一つはこれは僕なんかよくエンターテインメントって言ってるんですけど難しい
ことを抜きにして何でもやっぱり楽しくあるべきであって何何を楽しくするということ
たとえば a とこの前もあの病院の待ち時間がすごく長いとあの時間をどうやって
楽しくすることができるか
信号待ちしている時をどうやって楽しくできるかそういうことを考えながら生活をする
とまたそれで考えたことをどう実際作るかっていうことを
いつも実践しているというのかというのは少しずつよく変わるんじゃないかなと
なので8決闘目と足と口
まあ僕たちが持っている素晴らしいセンサー等をですね
フルに活用して
いろんなものをあの作っていければなと思っています
なのでえーっと子供達もここにいるあの大人たちも僕も含めてなれるものは8絶対に
無限大だと思っています
これから何をするか下から何をするかで何かが変わっていくと
なのでもう一度あのここでみなさんに聞きたいのが
大きくなったら何になるのと
ここにいる皆さんは大きくなったら何をするのでしょうか
そういうことをずっと心にもって
いろんな仕事とかもしくは生活ができればもっと楽しくなるんじゃないかなと思っ
いますありがとうございます